made your network stand up yes
television debut on my show way back in
1994 yeah when we were both 11 year old
girls and yeah and I remembered you were
really funny but I have a vague memory
of you put at the end putting something
into your standup that we didn't that I
didn't know you were going to do that we
didn't know you're going to do and in
1994 it was something you couldn't do
right and we end up having to take it
out yeah because if we hadn't taken it
out there could have been uh terrible
ramifications you would not be sitting
here right now going into I left that
bit in you would have been there was a
rough bit it was like I did well as I
remember we did very well uh uh it was
but I wasn't aware that I snuck it in uh
that's what I was that's what I was told
I don't I was told to but I I don't
recall that I don't think that's
something I would have done I mean I got
balls but not that big a ball like my
network debut okay so so maybe it's
misunderstanding over the years but I
remembered we had to edit it out it was
a it was a bit about Jesus yeah and and
a bit you could probably do now oh sure
but in 1994 a different world you in
comedy you didn't even mention Jesus
even favorably you didn't say yeah and
I'm nothing it was just you couldn't go
near Jesus well I I don't know about
that in 94 that's what I remember um but
it but you're also Catholic right no we
raised Catholic I'm an Orthodox Jew same
same thing no no I raised Catholic yeah
so I might have been over Lycia yeah
yeah so I'm it's it's a potentially you
know um there's especially if you didn't
know that I was gonna do it right then I
I understand but I I think the bid is so
it's pretty innocuous it is yeah it was
uh it was about how actually the bits
probably never been on TV well I think
about it um but it was about how we
didn't we don't know what Jesus Christ
sounded like there's no audio equipment
and would it be interesting if piece
his voice if he sounded like a really
effeminate southern man right and I
would do this whole you know Jesus you
know like have y'all been the Lazarus is
tomb free it did really well and it was
funny and I remember at the time walking
out and people were just in a we've gone
to DEFCON nine what are we gonna do
about that and so uh you know I can I
can definitely see that happening yeah
personally knowing out TV works yeah
you